welcome to this video playing Thai curry
Thai curry from finland finnish flag at
least ok is playing g3 a.m. let's just
play null solid moves and t4 i'll follow
a Kings Indian attack or reversed modern
perks defense something like that ok
I'll just play a play it simple simple
game trying to be quicken for a change
John what is why it's idea when idea
could be night age for 235 maybe maybe
you can do that right edge for me ok
either does that does not seem to be his
plan looks like you wants to fianchetto
and be too ok it didn't react to my a5
in any way so I'm going to push a form
but quite often can be a useful device
pushing the the flagpole to to gain some
space on the queenside and irritate the
other side of it
ok I would like to play a six-year to
make my pieces mom about this bishop
mostly yeah interesting he maybe wants
to play Knights you for whom yeah I can
go to c5 this is my idea and maybe maybe
I can push him back with b5 must be
carefully considered though yeah this I
didn't really expect but maybe he can
actually play a damn it looks it looks
we do we are weakening but if he gets in
a 5 this is sam this is maybe a playroom
what happens if i play Queen f7 taking
the slide I do that yeah that's usual
quickly played Quincy seven he needs to
go back right
okay I can you can go to a five it's not
the ridiculous what to do now I mean I
would like to get this stuff back so all
nice to to give up a pong temporarily
but at the end you you want it back okay
um he can play Quincy for maybe a
quickie form yeah but it's not the end
of the world I think I don't need to
hurry too much with getting the material
back it's it's not such a big issue the
pawns are really very weak so i can know
i can pick them up later I think should
I exchange rook da the other screen
g-form but not not really comfortable
okay but still it's not it's not a big
deal I just saw that I can do it anyway
look at the edge
yeah I think I should be really a in the
end game with this nice pawn structure
Queen g4 I have queen d 7 it's really a
shame that Bishop c4 Queen takes us
check otherwise it would be a would be a
really cool way to win with Queen d1
checkmate is there some way to set this
trap it would be it would be really cute
to get this in may be here intending
Bishop c4 but almost any move that you
can play as soon as nope okay so i'll
i'll win the Queen and Queen d1
checkmate Quincy for Queen D one minute
yeah sometimes you should just just play
a little trap right resins yellow before
you ran into this this kind of kind of
trap though it was it was okay for white
I think I mean I don't mind my position
yet it's it's really those are very weak
but um why it is still reasonably okay I
believe maybe Bishop here or something
Queen print here it's not really not
really anything special he can do that
but it's not helping him so much maybe
just not sufficient page free could be
it could be a move maybe also trying to
exchange those it's probably about equal
I don't think there is anything special
going on you should have enough
resources to m2 to avoid of bed end game
I mean this this can lead to a bad end
game rather easily if we trade some
pieces and
I can very often just get one of the
pawns back like the a four-point for
example and then he would be left with
two big horns on on on a 3 and C 2 but
with good play should probably avoid it
okay thanks for watching